Mày hả mình sò thằng sau cho tự thường viện căm bu chiều hùng xanh đã có chuyến thăm tình
ổ đà mình chay, giác xanh với thái làm, giới lúc căng thẳng hai nước tiếp tục sò tăng.
Ông hùng xanh giữ cơ bận dân dự tướng năm sau, đự rau thiên phải chào tướng hộ cần cấp cao,
phù trích giám xán và bảo đảm hộ cân chứ lực lượng cà bu chiều đồn chú tại bình dưới.
Theo người phân ngôn thường viện căm bu chiều chia trivwi,
Ông hùng xanh nhấn mạnh yêu cầu duy trị cạnh giác, sẵn sẵn trị đấu.
Châu khi đó, thủ tướng thái làm, bây trường thân xin nói tra cùng ngày,
cũng đáng thịn xá thịn trân nè, rân nè, râng trẻ tình xa cạo.
Bà chờ biến đằng lạnh giá, chiến dịch chống tội phạm xuyên giới,
và tất cả động tư việc sức chạp cứ cửa khẩu với cám bu chiều.
Chúng đau thái làm đẳng rừng toàn bộ phương tiện, khách xô lực và thương nhân qua lại
tại tất cả cửa khẩu đường bộ với cám bu chiều.
Bà chờ biến muốn thay só tất cả động tự chính xác, và chính phủ sĩ xem xế khẩu trở.
Khẳng thẳng xong phương gun đây, bị thúc đầy mởi bộ xong dị kiếm của định đam dưới lãnh đạo hành lớt,
cho khi bà phía trường thân hiện đối mặt với điều tra pháp liếp.